liberté seul mot d'ordre des ces
manifestants pourtant au 17 juillet
l'entrée en vigueur du qr code n'a pas
encore été votée mais ils sont près de
114 mille personnes a défilé partout en
france selon le ministère de l'intérieur
certains politiques de l'opposition
soutiennent mouvement anti pas
sanitaires à l'instar de florian
philippot chef de file des patriotes une
semaine plus tard la contestation est en
hausse plus de 161 milles personnes
descendent dans les rues dans toute la
france dont 11000 à paris
après plus de soixante heures de
discussion le parlement adopte le projet
de loi d'extension du pass sanitaire
avec quelques modifications du texte
initial la menace de licenciement pour
les salariés réfractaires au nouveau
sésame est notamment mise de côté
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants et l entériner pour le
troisième samedi de mobilisation les
manifestants sont encore plus nombreux à
battre le pavé plus de 200 4000
protestataires sont recensés sur tout le
territoire dans la capitale la
manifestation donne lieu à quelques
tensions avec les forces de l'ordre
selon une étude de harris interactive et
euros agency pour lci quatre français
sur dix soutiendrait la contestation
contre le pass and i ter dernière
manifestation avant l'entrée en vigueur
officielle du pass à lithaire le 9 août
encore une fois l'affluence est en
hausse dans les manifestations plus de
deux cent trente sept mille personnes
qui défilent ainsi à travers le pays
avec encore plus de 210 mille opposants
mobilisés la contestation est encore
importante mais pour la première fois
depuis le début du mouvement le nombre
de manifestants anti pas sanitaire est
inférieur à celui de la semaine
précédente
florian philippot continue néanmoins de
protester contre cette loi
deux juges notamment inégalitaire et
nous disons il faut retirer cette loi de
la honte et il faut gérer autrement les
choses pas en permanence en
instrumentalisant la peur par des
mesures liberticides par ds que vous
voulez pas ta douleur d'égalité entre
française du monde saluait il faut gérer
sereinement cette affaire en ciblant les
personnes généralement les traitant en
rouvrant des lits à l'hôpital faisant
confiance
la baisse de la mobilisation se confirme
lors de ce sixième samedi de
rassemblement cent soixante quinze mille
personnes se sont néanmoins déplacer
pour dénoncer le pass and i ter sur
l'ensemble du territoire
quelques grenades de gaz lacrymogènes
sont tirées par les forces de l'ordre à
toulouse pour disperser la foule malgré
la rentrée la contestation pourrait
continuer lors des prochaines semaines
de son côté le pass sanitaire sera en
vigueur jusqu'au 15 novembre pour autant
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
a prévenu ce jeudi qu'il pourrait être
prolongée si le coc vie 19 étaient
encore présents sur le territoire